on baille 250 000 fois dans notre vie
mais est-ce que vous êtes déjà demandé à
quoi ça sert de bâiller bon de toute
façon maintenant vous vous demandez donc
on y va au début on croyait que c'était
pour bien oxygéner notre cerveau mais en
fait non ensuite on a pensé que c'était
pour refroidir notre cerveau quand il
surchauffe mais en fait pas sûr en fait
bâiller ça sert à rester efficace
c'est-à-dire 1 vigilant on va aller
quand on est fatigué ou quand on
s'ennuie et ça nous met un coup de fouet
2 détendu en baille quand on est stressé
et du coup ça relâche les muscles
d'ailleurs essayez de vous forcer à
bâiller la prochaine fois que vous serez
en stress vous verrez 3 c'est moins
connu mais on baille aussi quand on a
faim c'est comme une alerte qui nous dit
attention la faudra peut-être penser à
manger parce que c'est bien d'être
vigilant et d'être détendu mais si on a
rien dans le ventre on n'est pas
efficace et 4 certains animaux baillent
aussi avant de s'accoupler alors perso
j'ai des humains j'ai jamais vu ça
pas sûr que je l'aurais bien pris
d'ailleurs